demand all hospitality workers be  brought back to work  a rowdy night in las vegas turns to  criminal mischief now the owner of a  downtown hotel is disappointed that his  unofficial mascot is out of commission  casino owner derrick stevens appreciates  a good time but not at the expense of  hotel property revelry went too far so  there's a lot of damage stevens  releasing this surveillance video  showing nearly a dozen partiers dancing  around a fountain at the d last weekend  but when one reveler gyrates on the  bronze statue it tumbles and the group  scatters i mean it took nine months to  make medic at this and  we're still trying to figure out  whether he can be salvaged or not it's a  replica of a whimsical statue in  brussels belgium depicting a naked boy  urinating into a fountain the vegas  version is sidelined for now  he represented everything we wanted just  having fun and all that so  to have this happen to happen to my  little guy  pretty sad for our whole our whole team